[Musique]
le chantier a débuté en juin 2010 9 le
bâtiment native a été conçu par le
promoteur immobilier codic avec comme
locataire le groupe orange une
infrastructure de dix neuf mille mètres
carrés avec huit étages pour en parler
nous sommes avec yann le gall le
directeur général adjoint de codic
france bonjour bonjour nicolas
alors où en étant dans ce chantier eh
bien écoutez on est dans le run final à
savoir que nous devons livrer cette
opération dans six mois à orange donc le
principal locataire de l'opération et
hsbc qui l'a acheté pour le compte de ça
et ces pays elise et pierre alors
quelles sont les caractéristiques de ce
bâtiment écoutez c'est le dernier né de
codic france donc c'est une opération je
dirais up to day they qui intègre tous
les besoins essentiels des utilisateurs
et d'ailleurs elle a été plébiscitée par
un grand utilisateur de la région ile de
france qui est le groupe orange vous
l'avez dit l'idée c'est de pouvoir
permettre à orange d'adapter ses modes
de travail et de pouvoir travailler
notamment tout ce qui est en mode projet
voilà et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup de l'obsolescence du parc
tertiaire alors avant on en parlait
plutôt sous l'angle de la performance
énergétique et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
l'enjeu qui nous anime c'est pouvoir
permettre les nouveaux usages et pour ce
faire on adapte la technique de nos
bâtiments et notamment par exemple tout
ce qui est le renouvellement d'air et
puis je suppose c'est dans l'air du
temps l'aspect environnemental aussi
prises en compte bien sûr alors ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on prend en compte sur
nos opérations depuis de nombreuses
années cet immeuble est bien évidemment
multi labellisé avec et bizet évidemment
le label hpe qui est un label français
géré par certivéa on a également le
label breeam où on vise l'excellence sur
ce label qui est un label international
et puis également un nouveau label qui
s'appelle le wire score qui permet de
certifier la connectivité du bâtiment
donc là on sort du spectre
environnementale mais c'est quelque
chose qui est très important aujourd'hui
on le voit notamment avec l'avènement du
télétravail il faut que les gens
puissent travailler à distance et pour
ce faire il faut que les immeubles eux
aussi soit connecté vous l'avez dit
livraison mars 2022 mais le travail de
codic sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines n'est pas fini alors il pas
finie et puis surtout c'est une histoire
qui dure depuis maintenant des années
2000 puisqu'on a déjà des réalisé plus
de cent mille mètres carrés de bureaux
sur sur le territoire l'avenir de codic
sur le territoire ces deux opérations
une qui est juste à côté donc deux
natives qui est vraiment une autre une
opération hypercentre posé sur la gare
rer de saint quentin en lieu et place
d'un immeuble emblématique qui s'appelle
l' anneau rouge voilà qui est un
immeuble totalement vétustes conçu dans
les années 70 et aujourd'hui encore une
fois en partenariat avec les pouvoirs
publics on travaille sur une opération
qui fera à terme 25 mille mètres carrés
l'idée c'est de redonner depuis le parc
des sources de la bièvre une perspective
sur la gare de saint-quentin est amené
deux immeubles de part et d'autre avec
les nouvelles caractéristiques du bureau
qu'on évoque et sur lesquels on n'arrête
pas de on n'arrête pas de dino d'innover
donc c'est le prochain défi de codic
réaménager l'espace vraiment proche de
la gare voilà alors on a deux projets il
est effectivement celui ci extrêmement
centrale et puis on a travaillé il ya
quelques années sur le sur le pas du lac
donc à quelques encablures d'ici donc
dans un environnement un peu plus vert
et là on travaille avec un autre
architecte qui s'appelle ateliers de 3,4
sur un projet de campus urbain dans
lequel on va développer un concept de
bio philly extrêmement importante parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'enjeu des entreprises
de demain c'est de faire revenir leurs
salariés au bureau leur donner un cadre
de vie agréable et surtout de perdre de
pouvoir permettre des échanges puisque
c'est ça qui fait avancer aujourd'hui
nos sociétés ce sont des nouveaux sujets
à suivre sur tv 78 les futurs projets de
codic merci yann le gall pour ces
précisions merci de nous avoir dit je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
général adjoint de codic france et puis
on va tout de suite rejoindre le
locataire le groupe orange pour nous
expliquer comment il va utiliser ce
nouvel espace
[Musique]
eh bien nous avons rejoint jacques
travail à le directeur adjoint des
projets immobiliers pour le groupe
orange bonjour bonjour nicolas
alors vous allez être l'utilisateur de
ces espaces sept étages c'est ça sept
étages sur huit est donc comment voulez
ça allait l'utiliser combien de
personnes vont venir ici et sur quelle
activité alors 1200 calories borat
heures orange vont nous rejoindre vous
rejoins de l'immeuble en d'ici juin à
septembre 2022 1200 collaborateurs qui
sont principalement des chercheurs des
techniciens réseaux est également une
équipe commerciale alors on le sait
orange c'est l'opérateur téléphonique
vous déployez aussi la fibre la
connexion de demain la 5g aussi sur quoi
vont travailler sur quels sujets vont
travailler ses collaborateurs les
collaborateurs de native donc localisés
sur saint quentin en yvelines vont
travailler sur la région sur le pôle
régional en lien avec les directions
centrales de ligue de france
pour moi je dirais développer le réseau
orange et le service au client par
exemple qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer ici sur ce plateau alors vous
avez imaginé à la fois des espaces de
convivialité des espaces de réunion des
espaces collaboratifs des espaces de
concentration sur l'ensemble des
plateaux évidemment
l'espace du huitième étage avec sa
terrasse va abriter une cafétéria
également un corps power king pour
également abriter les itinérants sur sur
le secteur et profitiez en fait j'irai
du plus bel espace avec cette vue qui
est extraordinaire merci jacques
travailleurs pour ces précisions merci à
vous nicolas je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur adjoint des projets
immobiliers pour le groupe orange et
puis bien aux rendez-vous dans un an
fait exactement au plaisir